you
[Music]
all right so WT is going to go nice with
that efficient port architecture search
is a very fast approach to doing no good
thanks John
so yeah so today I'll talk about a
method for doing neural architecture
search but before I even talk about a
particular method let's see like you
know why we care about searching for
architectures right so this this was
when I was visiting John in New York in
April 2000 18 and this is actually a
picture from dense nets right and
actually wait before we haven't begin
like you know how many of you would say
are very comfortable with at least
basics of training a neural network
right ok great and tensor flow pie
charts you endorse ent K you know one of
those supervised learning you have you
have trained a neural network on some
data set so often what happens is so is
that hey we have to figure out how many
layers we need we and and let's say this
is a data set that is new right it's
it's not a standard well-known data set
on which there has been a lot of like
communal domain knowledge right like
people have tried stuff published stuff
but this is your own proprietary first
party data set and its massive so what
should be the capacity of your network
how many what should be the particular
stride length or how should you connect
these things to each other like the
layers to each other and this is all
very frustrating right and you are
sitting there and you're trying things
and you know you have a are GPU budget I
am sure it's not unlimited and you want
to try out many of these things and you
want to achieve like some kind of
performance that you care about right
like you know I want good performance I
don't want to use too much GPU Ram
because during production time that
means I have to allocate too many
machines for serving I don't I also
wanted to not have this much more than
this much latency so there are all these
like multiple objectives that you want
to ideally do but but even before you
get to all of that in the beginning you
have a new data set new task you just
want to figure out something that works
reasonably right
and let's stick to supervised learning
we are not going to talk about
reinforcement learning
we will talk to enforcement learning in
the in the solutions methods but we will
not the tasks will be supervised
learning right and so and and here's
here's the truth like nobody really
knows how to set these things like
including people who are experts in the
field and and if everyone invented
neural networks back in the day right
like we do know this is all trial and
error this is very empirical work and
and this can feel very like you know
magic like we have all these magic
numbers floating around and not only
this we have magic numbers floating
around in the training parameters right
like that is not even in this picture
right what's the learning rate what's
the learning rate schedule how should we
warm start what should we initialize the
way it says and then this and and this
is the big motivation for trying to take
this guesswork out of humans into the
hands of algorithms right and hence
there is this very nice subfield of
machine learning now called neural
architecture search and and we and we
have all these like you know problems we
talked about and there's also like a
massive talent shortage right and I
think this room has a biased sampling
but in the real world getting people who
have the right skill sets and hiring
them and training them if needed is is
not easy right and and if you are out
there in the field you you probably know
this much better than I do so we are
going to do first before we dive into
our particular method a 15 minute
literature overview right and and before
we even go there into the literature
overview we are going to look at like
okay what is the problem definition
right so the problem definition is we
have a search space and and remember
this is not very difficult right like
you know this is not very complicated
all I actually want to do is give given
a search space which is the set of all
realizable like you know neural network
architectures I want to find an
architecture that fits my like you know
all my off criteria like it has this
much accuracy this much latency this
much things if possible or come as close
to them as possible and and and aMDA
right and and the training procedure
that hopefully can train it
and I'm all good so as with any search
algorithm this is no different than any
any search algorithm right like if you
are doing search in any ways all the
same things come into play there's some
sizzurp some trick challenges which is
the third column but the first one is we
need a search space right if you are
searching something you need to define a
space to search in and and we will see
that there are usually two kinds of
space and in the informal lingo we will
they will either be called macro or
micro and and we will see examples of
that so right so and a lot of like right
now you like you know domain engineering
goes into what should be the right
search space because here's the trick
right like if I can somehow come up with
a search space which I know will have
all the right primitives like you know
it has the conv layers it has
transformers it has self attention units
and all of these things match
normalization and all the right
operations and I can also inject some
priors into the search space that hey I
know that if I have a convenient after
that I should not be doing a batch
normalization this way I know let layer
normalization works from other empirical
papers I can I can prune out the search
space by just injecting a lot of human
domain knowledge right and and and that
that itself like you know and then this
debate right now is like you know how
much in domain knowledge should I inject
into the search space and what which one
should we work on right so we will look
into some details of that and pros and
cross now once you have a search space
the big problem in in architecture
search is that your search is very
expensive right so because because
here's what I really happens right in
order for you to try out architectures
one after the other what you like and
find the right one you literally have to
somehow find an architecture train it
all the way to the end and imagine you
have a data data set which is image net
size or if your language this is like
training a bird model or something right
this and and this is becomes your
subroutine you use some there is some
algorithm which is search algorithms
which is searching for architectures and
giving you an architecture somehow and
your worker threads have to go and try
them on your data set and then they will
report back some statistics like Oh
particular architecture has this much
memory uses this much latency this much
accuracy and so on and you will take
these datasets and update your search
algorithm on what to try next or what n
things other things to try next and all
of these things actually happen is
synchronously in any proper
implementation but the all the
expensiveness of neural architecture
search comes down to the fact that every
time in order to evaluate a point
function evaluation is super expensive
that if so I have this like you know
search space of like in a first search
space of noodle architectures I pick a
particular point that point is an
architecture I have to go and train it
and this training can take like on for
GPU box like you know two days right so
this is super expensive so and and there
are like you know uncountably many of
them right depending upon how I define
my search space there could be easily
like you know these are discrete things
usually like you know I'm putting aside
continuous hyper parameter so they are
not really uncountably many but easily
you could have millions and millions of
things to try right so so which one
should I try I don't have like I don't
want to use 10 million hours of GPU
hours right and ok so the search
strategy is all about like you know how
efficiently can be searched through
through the things and then performance
estimation is is more like a sub part of
search strategy is when I'm searching I
when somehow I'm like oh this is looks
like a good candidate to try but by
using whatever algorithm I'm going to go
down and then see how well it performs
but I don't want to actually train it
for two days so let's say it takes two
days to train an imaginary data size
data set on like you know an s4 and a
GPU box how how quickly like you know
how approximately can I evaluate that
function derive a reliable signal of how
well it performs and or not and and and
get out right like you know without
being fully committed to it right
because that takes up a lot of time so
so usually if you look at like in a
neural architecture search literature
you most of the differences are along
these three dimensions right what's your
search space what's the strategy and how
you are doing performance estimation to
do things okay so let's look at define
some of the search space terms because
this is important right so this is the
what is called as a cell search space
and what happens in a cell search space
is let's see how many of you are
familiar with let's say Reznick okay
good so if you've you know resonate you
know that what happens in resonate is
there is this like you know really nice
like skip connection and there's a
resonate cell right and there are like
regular cell and then there's a
reduction cell oh that's - like you know
down sample the resolution increase the
number of channels what so on but
usually but really in resonate the
design is not that complicated if I want
to create like you know there is a cell
which is basically this little motif
structure right here and in resonate all
the cells are the same in this one it's
a little bit more general the motives
are different and all the cells and you
have all you all you are doing is lining
up the cells and connecting them via
skip connections right and if you want
let's say oh I want a bigger thing they
add more cells right and all the cells
are designed the same and this is very
popular in literature because the nice
part is you can inject a lot of human
domain knowledge right and and reduce
the search space your such base is not
fully general it's you are so let's say
you have you say that like hey I am
going to use the resonate like backbone
which is the skip connections that you
have between cells and I'm going to keep
the search space constrained to finding
the what the motive should be the cell
should be right and then if I want like
you know a bigger Network I just add
many of these cells together stack them
like this stamp
many of these cells together and I get
bigger networks right and as you can
imagine instead of like you know you are
not searching for what the outer
skeleton should be and this really
reduces the number of things you have to
try right with the number of your search
space really there is the lot of human
knowledge domain knowledge injection so
some smart people came up with Reznick
and we are going to utilize this
information that skip connections are
good and having these cells is enough
and it seems and we are going to figure
out what the cells
design should be right
and this is the most popular space and
then of course there's the other one
which is what you would actually expect
if you didn't know about the cell search
space right which is like well I have
like a fully general search space
anything goes any particular type of
connections and any size any wonky weird
shape is all is all on the table right
and this is obviously much much bigger
right and a lot of like you know
research eyes away from using this kind
of search space because hey event for
doing this research you need a lot of
GPUs right and and I will show you
results later that we show that actually
you can use this kind of search space
and you can be competitive with cell
search space even if you use a much
bigger search space and get similar
results right and okay this right now
the slides will make available either
through the website or email me so all
the links will be there so you don't
need to worry some some really good
people maintain this really nice list of
architecture search papers right and it
will just give you an example of how hot
this field is like ever let me see okay
so actually wait the browser is owned so
remember we are only in October there's
two month left in the year right so this
is so this is so there's a group in
Freiburg who maintains this like less
stuff like you know machine learning
papers with in neural architecture
search related papers which either are
published or not published and I think
the bold ones are published and this is
2019 okay and I'm scrolling down we are
still in 2019 okay a little bit more or
we are still in 2019 when I am surprised
I didn't expect I had to do so many okay
2018 I see 18 good 18 18 18
oh boy Evan 18 was pretty big hey 17
this is good right
17 17 will be much shorter 16 whoops and
then the list ends right and from 16
2017 16 you go all the way back to
ninety four ninety eighty nine eighty
eight okay so there was this big gap for
like I forget how do the math like 25
years or something where we didn't do
anything on that topic right and so this
is this is pretty incredible right like
you know just I think there are like 50
to 60 papers on archive every like I I
don't I I dread waking up in the morning
and looking at archive like okay so but
this is really nice survey article I
recommend reading because as hot that
happens with any field in which which is
going viral do you need to read all the
papers that came out just this month you
will have to give up your day job and
just sit and read that right you don't
have to that's the good news
because a lot of it is noise and there
are few key ideas that you really need
to know if you want to know when and I
recommend that survey paper for more
details and in within the this short
thing I'll spend five more minutes to
talk about like you know three or four
key papers right and then we'll move on
to our paper which will come and come
out in December but it's on archive so
the thing that actually started or I
should say restarted the the modern era
of interest right like in in
architecture such and as you saw like
you know this is not the first paper
right so this is probably like the tenth
or eleventh paper the first paper was
1988 the second paper was 1989 at CMU
and and but this one really like you
knows restarted so four or five years in
into the deep learning revolution
reactive reawakening this paper came out
right and this paper was super simple
some of you I think took the classes on
explore exploit and basics of
reinforcement learning so if you did
this this should look pretty trivial
right so I'm going to do this
a gradient method and if you don't know
RL or poly security and these words are
alien to you you don't need to worry
about it at all here's the simple thing
I'm going to take one neural network in
this case it's an RNN which basically to
get a sector set model because we are
going to encode neural networks as a
sequence of outputs right like oh it's
gone five Provera followed by a rail
loop road by a max pool and so on and so
forth so this RNN is going to like you
know output me by like unrolling the RN
and it's going to output me a network
definition right and so that that's I'm
calling to going to call that the
controller and when I get a network
definition from it I'm going to send it
off to let's say a worker thread or a
machine somewhere in the cloud and I'm
going to train it right on the data set
and let's say I have imagine a tour C
far or something as the data set - just
to give an example it will train I will
get some accuracy and some other
statistics back and I'm going to update
this so if I get really good things
happened for that particular like you
know network that was sampled by this
controller during the update process I'm
going to update in such a way such that
those kinds of networks will be more
likely right there's a little bit of
like you know very trivial math that
goes into how you will do the update
from this but it's very simple right
like you are just going to make the
network this network which spits out
Network other networks definitions make
good networks that the results of those
training more likely and the other ones
less likely but and we are going to use
essentially like supervised learning
updates right to do this and to give you
a very concrete example that controller
network takes goes along unrolls and it
gives you this like you know Oh number
of filters filter hide filter weights
try height so this is one this is layer
n and then you keep unrolling and it
will give you another layer so on and so
forth until you tissues stop and that's
your network definition and this became
quite popular right this is one of this
is a very well cited paper and
unfortunately and I will show you
results comparing all of this later this
this was extremely expensive like to do
sir Chauncey 410 yeah I forget the exact
number but it was like 1,800 or 3,000
GPU hours right and and this is probably
way more than you want to afford right
like you know in terms of GPU cost so
the next paper that came out made this
cost go from like 1800 GPU hours go up
then like you know a network which does
well on c-- fart and and imaginet do
like in a one day right so at that time
it achieved like you know I think it bit
humans at that time don't quote me on
that door on C 410 and as well as on
like you know penn treebank all those
numbers have gone way like you know more
accurate because this was 2018 and this
is 19 so this isn't by deep learning
time right in all the experiments they
used a single 180 TI GPU now this this
starts to look much more attractive
right like because the paper before even
though it was the paper that started the
let's say the we started the interest
was was pretty impractical right like
you know and that didn't seem like a
good method
it wasn't efficient at all this this
starts to look much more interesting and
attractive okay so so let's talk about
like you know how how you go about doing
this
this still did the same thing as before
where the the RNN sampling like you know
networks and then you went and trained
it and you updated the RNN and and
obviously you are doing all these
sampling things in parallel you sampled
let's say a thousands of networks in
parallel and you send them off 2002
worker threads and whatnot but note the
big expense what is the biggest expense
the biggest expense is the cost of doing
forward dropping back prop right like
and mostly back prop like is much more
dominating and updating all the weights
that is like you know if I sample like
10 different architectures and I send
them off I'm doing like you know 10
times how many a box times how many data
set points have been in every Airpark
well divided by the number of mini
Beth's size that many number of
backdrops and that's where all my like
forward prop and back prop said that's
where all my compute is going
this is the very expensive part what if
so this was this was a completely crazy
idea and then this will look barbaric
and when I mention it is what if it
didn't do that what if we let's let's
say I sampled five architectures to keep
it simple and the five architectures are
very similar to each other except the
differ in some edges right like oh I
have one architecture and it's it looks
almost the same as the one next to it
except like you know it has this edge it
doesn't have this edge right and let's
share their weights right so I'm going
to take take those two architectures put
them in the same computational graph so
let's say they have all these edges
common to them I'm going to let them
share it and I'm going to do one forward
prop and one backdrop through these two
architectures at the same time and I'm
going to update you like you know their
individual loss functions individually
but the gradients are like you know
flowing back in aggregate right and so
the the edges which are not common the
only see gradients form each of their
respective loss functions but the rest
of the network they all see like you
know all the bad gradients coming in and
and this sounds crazy right like you
know say and but very efficient because
what you are doing is I am just doing
one forward prop and back prop and let's
say I have K networks and all the K
networks I can evaluate or train at the
same time basically aggregating all
these these network structures together
so you have like partially connected so
okay here's example right so what you do
is like you know you okay here's one big
limitation you have to assume that there
is a big super graph like there is this
big graph from which all this which is
your search space which contains all
possible networks and you're sampling
from that and let's say so this for
illustrative purposes this is the big
graph right the fully densely almost
densely connected one and this red one
is one sub graph which is a particular
network right and that RNN sampled one
of these right and I took it and then I
ask that an example me another one and
let's say it sampled another one which
like all these edges were common but
instead of this edge it went this way
right and maybe something else happened
so all these edges which were common I'm
going to create this new graph which has
basically the superposition of these two
graphs together right leg take the union
of those two graphs so I will have some
edges which are different but all the
other edges are common and I will treat
that as one graph and I'm going to do
just one forward drop and backdrop
through this superposed graph it's not
really super position but just take it
as the Union right so these the edges
which are like you know there could be
edge which is common across like let's
say ten different graphs all at the same
time and and this really amortizes the
cost of search so you come down from
like and om so you might ask like you
know why will this ever work because the
edges should get specialized right like
so let's say there is an edge which was
which is a part of K different graphs
isn't this really bad because that edge
is now trying to be good for in terms of
like you know it's particular way to
values it will take on to trying to be
useful too many graphs at once right
like you know instead of specializing to
the particular graph each individual
graph it belongs to and the conjecture
is that we have some good regularization
effects but this works okay but if you
read the paper I couldn't find any deep
understanding of why this would or
wouldn't work in any many ways maybe you
can think of it as multitask learning
right like you are your regular izing
the weights by saying that like hey you
have to be good across many different
graphs multitask for the weights
perspective right so the weights have to
like you know learn the values such that
they're good across many different
graphs if you treat as every different
graph as a task right you lose you don't
have to call you at a task but right
like you know think I get some
regularization effects okay and you can
do use the same tricks to do sample get
us an RNN to sample another RNN right
and in RN and actually what happens is
your cells search and micro search are
equivalent there is no macro space RN
ends are cells right like you are just
rolling out the cells so everything
nice right and so on and so forth and if
you look at very quickly at the results
let's see yeah you come down from GPUs
like look at the number of GPUs 800 GPUs
these are the number of days that this
was the paper I showed you so multiply
this by this this is a huge GPU budget
and then we come down to one right and
after doing green like you know this you
were they were getting this and now we
come down to this right and there's also
the parent number of parameters so on in
almost every respect you you become this
was this is a strictly better uniformly
better on all them on the Front's that
you care about right so this is a good
paper to know okay and look and they
discovered like you know networks on
image data sets that you would probably
not come up with if you are a human
being meaning I don't know about about
you but I will not come up with this
right like there's no way I will figure
this kind of network out and adore and
in if you are doing cell search this was
the kind of things and this was the kind
of things but it doesn't really matter
but that the whole thing is that these
are not intuitive things that you will
sit and come up with right very likely
okay this is actually my favorite paper
and this is was between deepmind and CMU
called darts which came out right and
some time made last year
this one is nice there is no
reinforcement learning
there is no controllers oh by the way
feel free to stop me and ask me
questions any time it will be more fun
that way
because if you think about it it was
kind of weird that this thing the 2017
paper posed it as a fully as a full
reinforcement learning problem more so
than that the deposit has a stateful RL
problem and bit policy gradients right
and because you can actually have
gradient information here right so this
is like feature selection so why would I
like you know pose it as the hardest
possible setting and then that's that's
obvious in the numbers that you can't
come come get back that it's so
inefficient
right and finding something good and
there's some limitations here that they
do only like cell based and and you will
see very quickly why they can't really
handle big large space search spaces and
and they did really well and in terms of
such time so here's the idea and this is
very similar to the enos idea is that
hey imagine the following that I have
got so let's say I have so this is a
cell right like you know and the cell
let's say has four nodes and this is
just for illustration purposes zero one
two three and and the nodes here are
tensors and they are connected by
operations right so from this node so
let's say from going from zero to one
let's say I pick realm then it will take
the tensor at zero apply relu to it you
get a new tensor and I will make that
and that what that new tensor will show
up at us at one and they said like you
know you know what we are going to okay
usually this is a discrete optimization
problem right like you know if I keep
the hyper parameters constant finding
architectures it's a discrete
optimization problem I have to figure
out like you know which discrete
architecture I want they did this
continue a nice continuous relaxation
which basically means that I'm going to
keep consider soft weights right weights
over all possible architectures so let's
say there are three of the four for
illustration purposes I have three
operator so value con 3 comma 3 and max
pool and from zero I can go to one or
from two any of these nodes by using any
of these three operators right and
depending upon which specific choice of
operator I choose I get a particular
architecture right at every place right
I could instantiate a particular
architecture based on like let's say
this one was relu this one was max pool
and this one here was gone when so on
and so forth I get a particular
architecture but instead of that I'm
going to keep all possible architectures
around at the same time and I'm going to
keep weights on them so now we have two
kinds of weights we have weights on the
architect which are like you know the
weights that you would traditionally
understand like if I have a conflate
sand biases to
if you have biases at all to train in
that but then I'm going to have this
like new kind of weights called weights
over the architecture so I'm going to
have like you know let's say a weight
alpha 1 alpha 2 alpha 3 alpha 4 alpha 5
alpha 6 so on and so forth where one
alpha corresponds to one operation right
and if that alpha is very high that
means that the network like for example
here if like you know alpha 2 is high
that means that the optimizer is trying
to say that this one this for this
particular connection let's say value is
really good and for this one value is
really good this one cons are good and
so on and so forth right but note that
we are keeping everything around but
based on the optimization whatever
values of weights these take on are
giving you like you know a continuum of
architectures right and then this is
this is key and then if I want to like
you know tell you will ask like ok but I
all I want 1 architecture at the end of
the day you take the arc max over all
the edges and you get a particular
architecture right they take the best
weight and the corresponding operations
so and it turns out that you can do this
there's some so there's some
optimization background like this thing
is this thing called by level
optimization whereby level at the two
levels here as you can understand is I
have the inner loop is I want to train
my network the regular way and the upper
level is like maintaining weights over
architecture so I am going to do this
inner loop and oh this outer loop and
during all this time okay but this up
optimization is still efficient in terms
of backdrop forward of forward prop
because my cost of backdrop is amortized
across all of them all at once because
I'm in order to evaluate these weights
it turns out that all I need to do is
one forward prop and one backdrop and I
can get to update this right so again
like you know in s like things of like
you know now I'm going to just keep
continuous values over all the
architectures and I'm happy right so ok
one problem that you might guess is what
do you think would be a problem with
this like you know that this this sounds
good
there's some problems the the
optimization is approximate
and if you unless you delve into the
math you might not find but practically
would you want to do this right or what
do you foresee as the problem run time
so again this is like less than a day
right like the results are really good
like you know at least on see far
animation later but not right yeah
they're just as good as in as if but if
not better
something must really body okay those
three lines right on the trajectory what
does the lion Jeep engine have done in
like three times
no no it's each line represents a
particular operation it's an operator so
let's say you have a fax of operators
who like value max full count
and each line represents how much weight
did you give over each one of those
operators number of operators is like
almost uncountable cuz you can have any
number of type of parameter in terms of
inside inside that operator which makes
it a new operator right so assume the
hyper parameters are constrained three
by three what if you do six by six or
what if you do go by 12
see those it is you have a bag of like
fifteen or twenty operators usually it's
like eleven it's like on three by three
is one Operator gone five by five is one
Operator
and this is actually what you are
getting at is this other thing like in a
secret which will be released shortly
herbs you that does not constrain your
ship your service
yes and that's again like you know but
this is that's not common to dots that's
common in any cell search space right
like so you usually take this discreet
bag of operators like con 3 comma 3 is
one Operator which is distinct from con
5 comma fries right and they would just
show up as different lines here your
point is good so if I have like many of
these then if I have 20 of those I will
have 20 lines everywhere right
and and actually what you are I think
getting at is that now I have to put all
of these things into GP you damn right
and GPU Ram is is not that plentiful
right like let's say I have 16 gigs or
24 gigs so the fact that I'm and and I
don't have just have this one self right
like I have many of these cells together
so instead of like you know and and each
one of them has let's say a
floating-point 16-bit wait over each
operator right so I have this like
massive graph like which includes the
architecture super graph that I have to
put into GPU so it's not very like you
know memory efficient so which which
again means that like if I increase the
number of like you know operations to be
more reasonable and consider more
choices this thing is not going to fit
into GPU right so so this is the thing
that should bother you right so then
then this paper immediately came out
like few months after that I think less
than three months after that that came
out and yeah like by December this was
out where what they did is like if you
imagine that I can I only keep in GPU
Ram one path through all the cell's so
let's I have two three cells right like
and there they all have all these like
operators and the weights over them I'm
going to sample a path here like you
know through this cell I'm going to
sample another path through this cell
and sample another path through this
cell so that gives me a full path
through all these cells and then I'm
going to only at one time take that
sampled path and I'm and in practice I
will sample many of these things
together and then do the inner streak of
sharing the weights which are common
amongst all the samples so that I have
efficient in forward pop and backward
and only put those sampled paths in GPU
at any given moment of time and and so
this basically what that allows you to
do is like you know so these are like
the architecture parameter weights so
let us say alphabet I have for weights
and I'm and I somehow sampled I did have
like you know binomial distribution
flipped a coin and said picked this one
which means everything else gets masked
out right and and I picked that
architecture and and trained it right
and
including all the other samples I had
with me right so and that's why they
call it proxy list because this is the
other caveat in neural architecture
search world is that all the time what
people usually do is there because
things are so expensive that they find a
proxy data set which is usually like and
I'm going to take a reduced imaginate or
c fart and nobody really does em
stemness doesn't justin transfer right
like i'm going to take something which
is much tinier than the data set that I
actually care about but imagine you are
in the product product world like your
data sets are probably way bigger than
imagine right like let's say your data
set which is like 10 terabytes right
like this this is not something you
would want to do even on a 10 terabyte
data set right so what you will do is
what the common thing that people do is
you subsample a very very tiny data set
you train on that find a good
architecture and then you scale up right
and you scale and when I say scale up
usually what people will do is they will
take do cell based architecture search
find a good cell design and then they
will like just stack many of these cells
together right and then try that train
that on the full big data set once right
that you can afford to do right and then
the other things you can do is take into
account explicitly like you know so and
this is probably important when you are
serving time let's say you have a KPI I
cannot be more than 10 milliseconds in
during during the forward drop like you
know and you want to put that into the
search like bias the search - giving me
model models which are not just have
good loss but also have like you know
let's say good latency right like you
know not too high latency and because
this is also important to me and and
there are many other things you can just
put them in there right and and that is
not specific to this you can do it and
okay
so last year actually in the same series
I gave this YouTube the same talk but it
was much more of a tutorial format an
hour and a half so if you want to know
more details and including the ball what
really happens in the policy gradient
updates have a look at this and the
slides will be made available so you
will have the links
so issues further I guess there are
multiple cells put together is it like
for example today like a sinner one two
three so they follow like a different
step right yeah different stuff so like
a query like it's a convergence for a 0
to 1
I'd like a from 1 to 3 is there like a
difference from 2 to 3 like that errors
Network okay like I have come straight
on that what's the potential issue is
that I wouldn't I want to hear more
failure so I don't think I caught the
details like so are you saying that do
we have like convergence issues no no
you are asking like you for this is a
kind of architecture put this together
what are the potential yeah all I was
pointing out is that if you if you do
this thing that you maintain weights
over all your architecture your your
your memory the memory for required for
representing this graph blows up right
because for every so let's say you have
a graph with n nodes and V vertex V
vertices for every vertex you now
actually have times K vertices right
because K is the number of operations
you have in your bag right that you are
considering and and this means so this
becomes like an N node x kv like you
know that that's the size of your graph
and this is massive right so you can't
fit it into GPU memory
is that like a from but sample is one
two three versus like a two to three you
need to like vocal from oil for Therese
to the finest but what if you like they
have a conflict under under egg you're
like if the result doesn't emerge or I
go there you have some issues with the
term what if like it has completely
changes to some subset original
substance thank you friend in the in the
graphic from one to three they're also
three two to three so it's like a new
use I like it it's the best type I said
eventually I said using the same
architecture to do there to do the work
all you use like a sweetie from sounds
then the result out come out from
different cells might have like a
conflict ur oh you mean like oh I think
I think I understand what do you mean
like okay so this is a small detail but
it's an important detail right you you
can have compilation failures right like
so so let's say the RN n or or whatever
method you used you sample the graph and
the output so let's say from here to
here so let's say you used like a
confocal 2x2 which try to now this down
sampled it but the tensor coming from
here is a is twice the sample right so
now three has to deal with two inputs
coming in which are of different
resolutions right so this is compliation
failure usually when I'm writing it by
hand I will just make sure that things I
will do the math in my head that no this
will be like and see this tensor of this
size this many channels and I'm applying
this operator so I can do the math in my
head and make sure otherwise like you
know pipe torture tensor flow will throw
you like a size mismatch error right in
the first try so what what usually
happens is you do all these hacks right
like you know you you make sure you will
write extra boilerplate code that if
this do things that are coming in and
not of the same size I'm going to do a 1
Cross 1 convolution and increase the
number of chant filters to be let us say
the max of these two so that everybody
gets on the same tensor size right so
that like if I add them or concatenate
them or whatnot I don't get compilation
failures right so with that because
that's an important implementation
dealer you can
very much very easily get compliation
failure right like when you when your
sample or network okay okay so there's
much more details here and the slide
deck is I think for that is also
available so okay so now let's see you
have 20 minutes so we're calling this
project petri dish because as opposed to
most of the methods that I showed you
where we were doing basically something
called backward search so darts enas and
that RNN the first paper that I showed
you which are like good three principal
components of literature it there is
this implicit assumption which is in the
technique that somehow you have the
super graph that I get this like in a
big graph and from which I can sub
sample and Troon down and search for a
good architecture right and and and in
and and okay and that that's also human
domain knowledge that you have to inject
right let's say you get a data set which
is not vision which is not just an LP
and whatnot so you have really no
intuition on what is a good super graph
to start with and how big should I make
it right the bigger you make it the more
such time you will take you may be able
to squeeze out more performance at the
end if you are willing to spend more
such budget in GPU hours but it's also
mean you may be very wasteful right so
what if instead of doing backward search
which is all 99% of the papers out there
we could do forward search and forward
search basically like you know you
should think of we call it petri dish
because like in a petri dish we are just
growing the network as needed right and
like you know we it has the following
flavor that we will start from a very
seed network like you know let's say one
or two layers and then we will see hey
should I add another layer or not right
and if I if I want to add a layer what
kind should it be right and this is the
the mathematical question we are going
to pose and we are going to try to find
an algorithm that will do this now
what's the nice part about this doing
this forward instead of backwards I I
don't need all that things and second I
also can do macro search which is the
more general like I don't need to assume
that I have a cell and I have to do that
do go and like you know reduce the
search space whereas you made a lot of
human domain knowledge into a cell I
also don't need another knowledge of a
backbone
right like if you go into your resonate
like backbone or dense net like backbone
yeah yeah and then one nice part is hey
let's say you had a 10 terabyte data set
you have a really good model for that
day comes I usually go by day and says
hey I haven't this really cool method
you should try this but instead of
trying that what you want is like hey I
have this method I have this really good
thing can you start with this and modify
this instead of like you know undoing
all the work we have done to come up
with a good model right because we
actually have put in a lot of like you
know expertise and domain knowledge to
come up with this model and it's right
now it satisfies this right and and so
you want that property and it's not easy
to do those things with like this the
previous methods because they have the
flavor that hey give me a data set I
will try things and give you an
architecture right so you it's not how
easy to warm start from something that
already exists and then also like you
know explore apply a prior knowledge
okay so before how many of you know
gradient boosting does the word ring a
bell okay all right so even if you don't
know it doesn't matter but for this but
if you do know then keep keep gradient
boosting in your head and it'll come in
useful right like an ax you can
understand why is just like for example
if you are training like you know for
example XG booster or in and and
training like a forest of decision trees
via gradient boosting which is a very
powerful method for especially for
tabular data or where you've know the
low-level features already pretty well
or they have semantic meaning you are
doing boosting boosting is this like in
a general term where you are like adding
weak learners one by one right and you
are growing in scope and capacity and
this look with this this will feel if
you know gradient boosting this will
look very much like that okay and in
fact one of the earliest papers so we
were inspired by this this paper was
1989 I think the depth report is 1991 is
cascade correlation at CMU and there
one of the things they did actually I'll
skip this because I can just show you
the correct method right and this way is
you start with a small model like you
know and let's say this model is tiny
and you you somehow have these
candidates right like and let's say
these candidates are like you know this
grab bag of operations right like a con
5x5 max pool so on and so forth right
and I want to know where I should add
these candidates if I were to add this
without actually adding them in I want
to know how useful these candidates are
going to be if I were to add them in
right so this is kind of like asking a
very hard question like well you say you
want to know how useful they are why
don't you just add them and evaluate
them right so but that's going to run up
my GPU cost because if I add them into
the network and then I have ten
different if I have ten different
candidates I have ten different networks
I'm going to have to train ten different
things and bad like you know I don't
want to do that I want to like try them
all at once but without really trying
them and without affecting the original
model and then I want to see if some of
them are useful I'm going to add them in
like behavior add them in means they
will just become a new network right a
regular Network with that particular
thing added in and then and and now I
can repeat this process right off like
for and and I will may take that model
which which has become modified put it
here and repeat this process again how
am I going to actually do this because
this seems like magic so let's say I
have this simple in original model right
and and this is a regular blue lines
much irregular connections here's really
the fun part right like so I let's I
have a candidate one candidate right and
I want to add it in such a way during
that middle the initialization phase
where I see whether it's actually what
signal it can receive it can provide
without actually affecting the gradients
the activations or the gradients which
are flowing back through the blue things
and I can actually do that it's not that
hard is let's say this can
I decide to add it here I I connected by
this particular type of this dotted line
where the forward is identity the
backward is zero so if you electrical
engineering if you heard of the term
Zener diode this is basically like that
right that this is a this is a special
type of layer where forward activations
will flow through just like just as is
but back backward gradients will be
stopped right so and then we have the
reverse of that which is here this one
which is the forward is zero which means
that if I am like doing forward drop
this is this is zero this is just as it
is so the sum is just whatever the
activations of B are and then it goes
through C so we have verified that
during forward activations we don't
change the the activations that would
have flown through the blue ones right
everything is unchanged and during
backward propagation let's see so you
will get signals this one the backward
is identity so you will get gradients up
to here but no more gradients here right
and the gradient from here will actually
be the original one of B right because
there is no there is no dependency on
this candidate so so during forward and
backward nothing in the original graph
changed but I get to see some gradients
here and this should remind you of
gradient boosting right because now I
can accumulate what the gradient is in
that candidate with respect to B right
because the B is right next to it and I
can see in that candidate what gradients
I am getting and and here's the
intuition right like you know if the
okay and and this this is the
inspiration that comes from Scott
original paper is hey if this gradient
is actually very highly correlated with
your error right which which gradients
are then what I'm going to do is that
that that gives me a signal a proxy
signal that discs adding this candidate
is good because then if I add this
candidate into the main network and
train it I can refer it will it can
learn weight and coatings which are
reverse of the error and minimize the
error residue like let us say right now
I have some error
even if I were to add this in I have
good conflict I have I have it on good
faith that this will be able to actually
minimize the residual of the error with
respect to what the target values I want
right and you can do whatever regression
classification it doesn't matter so if
you decide so that was the middle middle
one right and if I decide that I want to
actually add it so I will add it in
gently because I don't want and and this
is there's no theoretical reason for
doing this other than pure intuition is
that I'm going to just take out like you
know replace these with regular
connections that I should have no no
more special Zener diode like
connections but I'm going to make this
one one and this one zero in the
beginning the weights so that like you
know I don't have this big disruption in
the distribution of gradients that each
layer sees right and let the let
backdrop and optimize and figure out
what the right values of this weight
should be
but gently right from from here right so
in practice like you know so these are
called like stop gradient layers so
whatever operations you are considering
this one that is called a stop forward
layer and then once you decide that you
want them in you are going to remove
these things and create the just the
network right and with a scale value and
then let the network decide what it
should be right and okay so now yeah
let's hold that for three more slides
and if you still have that problem
tell me again right hopefully it will
this will become clear so one of the
things was we wanted to in order to be
efficient we know that we want to
amortize our cost of forward prop and
back prop right like this is a common
running theme right without that you are
not really efficient in GPU hours so I
want to try whether all these operations
so let's say I have K operations where K
can be 10 20
and I want to try whether I should have
which one of these K operations I should
pick here and which one of the same K
operations I should pick here and I want
it all in parallel so I can add them up
again by like you know doing these
particular like stop gradient stop
forward trick and I'm going to just on
one of the things we do is we impose a
l1 sparsity penalty on all the
operations so then we pick the operation
that has the most weight amongst the key
so so there's an l1 regularizer on all
of this plus an l1 regular eyes are on
all of this and we pick we greedily do
selection right so this is again like
gradient boosting we are doing greedy
selection and and and let's say we
decided to add something together so
then it will become a part of the model
and that happens in this middle stage
right so where we will remove them and
add the like you know the gentle
introduction and then that model will
move on to the third stage where it will
actually get trained fully right and
depending upon the signal will derive
from that we will we will decide whether
it will go back to being a parent model
so this is like a parent these are the
parents all the candidates are being
evaluated on the parents the parents
produce children and if the children are
good and seem promising they get to be
parents and like you know see whether we
are doing except this will remind you of
evolutionary search just because of the
terms I am using but it's not we are not
really doing evolutionary search here
right which is just as much as vs. RL so
yeah so and one of the things we do is
actually we do one start which is so all
the model weights we keep around and
when we and just these new layers that
we got added in those layers get their
new weights by backdrop they get updated
and and then they are always getting
incremental you trained right so over
time
so we can add layers anywhere right so
that's actually part of the decision
that you are saying is a that's a good
question is that you flip a coin and you
say like you pick one of the layers to
as the input input one you flip the coin
again and that gives you another input
too and then you make where you want to
be out right and so that means you are
keeping a lot of these things together
right so yeah and but and it's important
because you don't know where where you
should be connecting to right so that's
part of the search space yeah and this
is just saying what I just said and and
this whole thing is always happening in
asynchronously right in a distributed
manner that you have a pool of parents
they are going and and for every parent
that we are trying to figure out which
one of them should which candidates we
should add to which parent where and we
train them if we decide we like them and
then they get to come back okay now the
thing that I haven't told you is how do
we decide we like a candidate right like
I told you the mechanism by which we
would like a candidate right how do we
how do we know that these candidates
when they are added are worth going back
to the parent queue right so here's what
we do and this is nice because this is
important in the real world is as you're
trying things out a synchronously in all
these queues you are training them you
get to keep so this is a scatter plot so
let's say you care about flops right
this is your loss or accuracy this is
loss and this is cost so ideally you
want to find the parent of frontier
right and this could be memory this
could be latency anything you want or
all three of them ideally you want to
find the parent of frontier and know
that like what is the best possible
performance you can get for a given
flops budget and gives you the lowest
loss right and look that up and if
tomorrow you get faster GPUs or you're
serving needs change and you are like
hey 40 milliseconds is okay in these
kind of scenarios I want to just pick
this model out right like I don't want
to retrain my architecture search and
say hey give
model which is good for 40 milliseconds
right I already have this gallery of
models which is along this approximate
Pareto optimal frontier note I don't
know where the parrot optimal frontier
is but as I am training I get to have
this scatter plot the scatter plot is
building up right because these are all
the things that are at the end of the
third queue the child models I train
them and I get to just plot them here
right so the ones that I know so if you
think about it well I know for a fact
that there are models like for example
like this one as this if this was a
parent it is very highly unlikely that a
small modification right like adding a
small candidate layer would result in
the model which will lower the parrot of
frontier right like you know it's highly
unlikely I will go from here because I'm
adding something so which means I will
go this way but I will go have a huge
drop in loss right like you know I'm
making some reasonable smoothness
assumption that networks which look like
look similar have similar performance so
which means that there is really no
reason for me to add these models to the
parent queue right because I all I
really care about is here I want to
lower this as quickly as possible but I
don't know where it is right exactly the
frontier is it is quite possible that
this one even though it is slightly
above the parrot of frontier here I know
that it is possible it is like you know
this is an exploration exploitation
problem that if I were to take this and
make a dent to it that it will go really
down right and it'll lower the frontier
and then that's good news for me and so
we explicitly maintain this palette of
frontier during search and we look for
and we and on and we take a small
tolerance region around the boundary
because we don't know which model may be
promising and based on the distance from
the current estimate of the lower convex
hull of the frontier we we explored
right we we get to add them to the
parent cube and see if things will make
sense does that answer your question
okay
so results before we go to results
though I will want before I show you
numbers it's easy to show numbers but
there's a lot of caveats in this kind of
research and right now in the community
we have this like comparison and
fairness reproducibility crisis X
pruin just all of ml but NASA makes it
even harder why because everybody comes
up with their own search space right so
if so then it's hard to compare us
merits of a search algorithm not only
that one of the things we don't address
is like hyper parameter tuning right we
if and and it is very well known like
let's say if you are a competitor you
have a computing algorithm just because
you have a better like you know training
routine subroutine you can come up with
a very good like you know your
accuracies may be much higher right and
if you are using if you're training
subroutine for training a model a
network has all the tips and tricks like
cut out cut makes this kind of
augmentation has cosine warm-up in
learning rates and this and that and
that makes a huge difference you will
not even be on the leaderboard if you
have a rear end though you have a great
search algorithm and so so that that
makes that makes a huge difference right
what's your hardware people are
reporting GPU hours K 80 GPU hour is not
the same as a V 100 or like a TPU GPU
hour right or an FPGA deep you are so
what's your hardware we know we have
stack asset is sitting in training on
GPUs and like you know how many random
seeds how many trials you did so unless
you are a lab with lots of GPUs this may
be expensive for you to do and report
properly and this is also a multi
objective optimization problem right and
that it's not just about accuracy it's
about accuracy at certain flops or
memory or latency right we know that
like you know hey if you by using very
fancy distributed training I can train
like you know a two gigabyte model on
imagine it and be so town right and but
that's not very interesting you are not
going to use the two here and model in
production right and that's a really
uninteresting result so there's lots of
work being done like this one as bench
which came out where this is from Google
and the Fryeburg people whose link I
were showing where they actually went
and trained close 1.8 million different
architectures and put it in a lookup
table so if you want to like you know
for example evaluate your search
algorithm as long as you embrace that
but implicit search space you can just
do look up on your laptop you can do
Nasri search on a laptop by just
downloading that lookup table right
because it's like a few MB of
but but that had like things like weight
sharing and darts like subspaces cannot
really work there including our
incremental thing but more benchmarks
are coming soon
and the community I'm pretty sure will
rally around them and it will also bring
NASA research to communities who cannot
afford like you know unless you are a
big industry lab with like 5,000 GPUs
you won't even touch this right so it
will it'll democratize it a little bit
more okay results and as I said like you
know look at sovereignly this was like
1600 GPU days so converted into hour so
this is and okay we do well on both of
these fronts none of this is not going
to blow you out of the park but and we'd
and okay but yeah but you should not be
doing vanilla RL right so this is not an
RL problem and and we and we actually
showed that hey using macro and and and
you will see that some of these numbers
have plus minus and some of these don't
because there's also like you know
variance in how people report results
right like we actually run multiple
trials for different random seeds and
there's a list of best practices that
one should do for reporting any results
on any machine learning algorithm right
because we found that hey a lot of
people are taking the best results they
found during all their experiments and
reporting that that's essentially like
you know hey I threw a number of darts
and one of them struck gold and I'm
going to report that and put up the
trained model on github right and that's
not very honest right big and and you
should really put it have variances and
reproducibility and but I would not like
you know the results won't blow you away
because again there's no easy way for me
to show you that the gallery of models
we produced right like we are just
picking one of the points that our
algorithm produces and putting it on
this paper and this here just so that I
can show you some comparison right but
this is not a very fair comparison or
like apples to apples by any means right
and there's huge discussion that goes
into there right and one of the things
we were able to show that hey if you
transfer to imaginate which is this
process of taking a cell and adding many
cells and then training it you can
actually like you know with macro where
you have
you have no knowledge of backbone or
cells or anything you can do quite well
as close to cell search right skip the
language modeling and we are out of town
I sorry out of time and just to and like
you know there's lots of your research
problems and and NASA has really good
useful successes but it's no means a
solved problem right because if it was
solved we won't have to write
architectures by hand anymore but right
now like you know if you are like I
always tell people students or potential
PhD students that if your research
agenda in academia suddenly becomes let
me hand design a new architecture for
doing object recognition you should
really rethink that because nobody beats
nests right now on those kinds of things
right and okay we have like you know we
have an implementation on github but we
are a lot of that implementation is a
tensorflow and I know tensorflow is not
the most popular right now so we are
redoing everything in Python and we are
also making the code a little bit more
robust so watch that github link we will
will send out a blog post with all the
right things but one of the asks we have
is like you know you are from all over
the company is do can we get access to
first party data sets right like you
know we don't need to publish that the
method is published we have a patron a
defense a patent on it and like you know
interesting new datasets they know and
they don't need to be just vision and
language they can be anything we would
love to get our hands on and work with
you and try to see like you know what we
can do right just for our own curiosity
right if you have like you know
production serving needs and we have all
these kinds of like you want to take
into account give me the best model
which has less than three MB GPU Ram
right like that kind of scenarios would
love to get our hands on that and I will
and just too so that you have a bit of a
break
[Applause]